local people have vanished in fair
weather swallowed by the Prairie that we
know to fear and respect I wonder you
have by any chance run across the doctor
from Independence no I haven't seen any
doctor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
once again it's Tuesday and you know
what that means
it's time for a new episode of 13
o'clock this is episode 66 damn I know
right did I did I kinda did I kind of
sound like Casey Kasem just then and
also 66 haha episode 66 look until I
listen to radio a lot back in the day
back of the day for a while I think it'd
me yeah today's show we're going back
into the true crime well this was also
another request although again I can't
remember who requested it yeah but it's
actually the bloody bender yeah I've
never heard anything about this this and
this kills me
I hadn't really heard much about it
either like I've heard the name but I
didn't really know much about it I mean
they're essentially they called him
America's first serial killing family
right um which I guess they kind of are
you know we did the show about HH Holmes
and a lot of [ __ ] about him yes he was a
horrible murderer and stuff like that
but a lot of [ __ ] about him was
exaggerated a fake nose okay but like
this [ __ ] is not really exaggerated and
I feel like there's really not much
about this okay like I kind of looked up
you know there's a lot of blogs there's
a lot of websites obviously they have a
Wikipedia page they have a murder pedia
page but there's no like long-form
documentaries about them like I found an
episode of an investigation discovery
show called evil kin and they had an
episode about them there was a movie
made about them like an independent
movie made last year that was just
called bender and I've heard it was
alright but I it didn't seem to get many
reviews or anything like that and
actually if you're watching the YouTube
version the clip I put at the beginning
of the show was actually from the
trailer for that movie now just based
briefly on what you've told me so far
you know like in the past days you've
been researching this this is about the
closest you're actually gonna get to the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre being a reality
a family reading about it this is what
reminded me about and I've also seen
other Arthur articles online there was
one on I think wicked horror the wicked
horror blog that compared them to the
Firefly family from
Rob Zombie's you know how thousand
Corpses and Devil's Rejects and they are
kind of like that right now I want to
nip all this in the bud before we start
this program there may be
inconsistencies because a lot of the
research material has inconsistencies in
it because this is old this is an okay
and you always said these serial killer
fanboys you know jumping in and you know
thumbs down and and then you know not
cutting us any slack in the comment
sections look the material is
inconsistent yeah the source material is
he I just thought this was an
interesting story and I'm glad that I'm
glad someone recommended it because I
wasn't really familiar with it right and
like the more I read about I'm like this
is the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] ever it's
like why don't more people know about
this all right I mean it's not like
they're gonna teach it to you in history
class or anything like that this fine
this guitar plugs and announcements out
the way and we'll dive into this all
right so okay we only have a couple
plugs this week just wanted to say
obviously my book the faceless villain
if you're into true crime it's about all
about unsolved murders and it's the
first volume there's gonna be two more
the next one will be out next year print
copies selling real well yeah so the
print copies out the e-book copy is out
and I'm doing the putting the final
touches on the audiobook so I'll upload
that that'll be out in a couple of weeks
and you know I have I have a little list
of people that wanted the free audio
codes because I get 25 audio codes from
ACX audible you guys say be patient
you're on the list you're gonna get your
audio yeah as soon as it comes out cuz
like I said I'm sorry it's taking so
long yeah I wanted it to be really good
and perfect before I uploaded it upside
to this is a Jenny's kind of upgraded
the the audio program she's been using
this is gonna sound a lot better
hopefully yeah I think it's a lot better
than on scene and yeah hopefully
hopefully it does and one day we might
remaster unseen hand but we'll see yeah
we'll see how that goes yeah so if
you're into true crime and you want to
pick up the print copy and if you do
like it oh please leave a review and
thank you to everyone that's left a
review so far I also want to give a
mention to the podcast conspiratorial
with Adam saying I recorded a interview
with them it was about an hour and a
half long I think talking about a lot of
the kind of lesser-known cases that were
in the faceless Bell and so if you're
under intense offers and I will put a
link when that show
comes up probably on the Facebook page
and Twitter all that other kind of stuff
so you can check that out you know it's
him I was I jumped it on some bonus
material yeah we also and we also did
Tom and I both did some kind of bonus
material for their patron only uh you
know feed and we talked for about an
hour about I remember was we were
supposed to be talking about the
Cleveland torso murders which be kind of
did but then we kind of went off on a
bunch of tangent on that when I realized
how amusing I am every time I every time
I've opened my mouth those guys to start
laughing they say well you know what's
really cool about those guys well
against paranormal and it's a really
good podcast it's like they they're
actually big fans of ours yes I was
which is actually really flattered
drawback comments and jokes that I made
earlier shows and I'm going oh yeah we
don't script any of this [ __ ] so yeah so
sometimes like people like sometimes
people that listen to the show like
remember the set better than we do yeah
you know that's what happens also we put
up a new movie review well technically
not a movie review it was a TV series it
was the Logan's Run TV series from 1977
have fun making that one yeah that was
actually fun it actually had fun
watching it yeah this is yeah it was
much better than I was expecting
yeah you check them on yeah so if you
have then we have that up there also and
I think for our $10 and up patrons we're
probably gonna do a Google hangout this
weekend which for our American listeners
is the weekend after Thanksgiving
probably be Saturday Sunday whatever
I'll say almost time start cooking up
that cornbread I know right is it gonna
make that cornbread stuffing
yeah and cook a whole turkey and
everything yeah you gotta cook the
cornbread like several days before and
don't because it has to dry out a little
want to get a pecan pie I want to get a
pumpkin pie I want to apple pie to my
little boy and I'm gonna get put get
make some gravy I want all the pie I'm a
homemade cream style corn you know real
mashed potatoes yeah
giblet gravy yeah of course I'm all
about that all about the food these
people don't know how I cook man I keep
us fat over here man it's a constable
constant war dirty it's very hard to
keep our girlish figures were you the
one with a girl is man over here oh man
if I'm gonna pinch you yep that's all
man oh man
but yeah so Thanksgiving yell yes so
keep a lookout for that I'll send
invitations to everyone that's on the
list and also if you would please check
out our patreon page at patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast and if you
don't want to give them a flee donation
then you can give a one-time donation
through PayPal and that's you just go to
the blog which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a little link
in the sidebar
okay so let's get into the bloody
benders yeah yeah I want to hear about
this yeah cuz that you'll love this show
this is also you said yeah yeah all
right so let me set the scene it's a few
years after the Civil War around 1870
all right now the government has just
taken the the Osage Indians from Kansas
and have you know essentially booted
them off their land they sent them to a
new Indian Territory about 50 miles
south I believe in what is now Oklahoma
so the land that remained empty in
Kansas was available made available to
homesteaders this is during the westward
expansion and so you know if you go you
file a claim and you didn't really have
to do much paperwork you file a claim
you get some land you work the lands you
can keep it okay so around 1870 there
are five families and they move into
this one area of Kansas they're
spiritualists all right
okay this kind of plays a little bit
into it not much but you know I guess
you wish they're doing seances they're
doing yeah yeah I'm kind of rebooted
Christianity Yeah right this kind of
stuff so these these were the five
families that moved in around Osage
County and our Osage Township rather
they weren't morning know there weren't
more Missouri no they're definitely
spiritualist one of these families was
the Bender's now when I say family you
can't see me but I'm making little
ironic air quotes because it's not
actually known if they were actually a
family in the strictest sense but I not
have been related DNA was right but I
will get I will get to that short of
them so 1870 the dad either known as
John bender or
or sometimes as William bender for
whatever reason him and his quote
unquote son John bender jr. they travel
out there they lay a claim to 160 acres
and start setting up a homestead and
then a little bit later the wife whose
name is either Elvira
Elvira or Almera known as ma whereas
John bender senior was known as PHA so
I'll call the mod Paul bender because
that's essentially what they're referred
to as so MA and the daughter Kate bender
comes out with her later on so out here
on the Kansas prairie this is right
along the Osage trail and this is kind
of the main point where families that
are heading out west to you know set up
homesteads this is kind of the main
trail that they all go through so the
bender family they set up you know a big
like a big one-room kind of Shack but
you know I guess it was a house for the
day and they kind of set it up along the
side of the trail but a little bit off
the road so like you can't really see it
from the road but you know it kind of
gets around that it's there now what
they know about the family John bender
senior who is PHA he's in his 60s
evidently he is a German immigrant or
perhaps from Holland he's thrilled they
said he's a real big guy kind of a brute
of a guy didn't really speak English all
that well they said when he did talk you
couldn't really understand what he was
saying because he had such a thick
accent kind of kept to himself ma bender
her age estimated anywhere between 42
and 55 years old she supposedly spoke
German and no English although that
might not be the case and I'll get to
that later too she was apparently an
[ __ ] like she was apparently really
mean it got a learned that she was like
really mean they called her a she-devil
right things of that nature now the son
John Jr he was in his mid-20s about 25
26 said to be a pretty handsome fella
although they said that he kind of had a
tendency to kind of giggle at random
times so they kind of thought maybe he
was you know special right
that also might not have been the case
and then there was the daughter Kate
bender who was around 22 23 now by most
accounts she was quite a beautiful girl
and real flirtatious real social real
outgoing and this is supposedly the
daughter yeah okay supposedly now she
was also but she built herself as a
psychic and a healer she could talk to
the dead she could heal deafness and
blindness she could heal all these
diseases and they still have there are
extant still flyers that she would pass
around the area and she gave lectures on
spiritualism she held seances and so the
fact that she built herself this way and
was evidently a really pretty girl like
on the Prairie and stuff so this kind of
encouraged more people to come to this
house because what this family did was
they took their house and they divided
it in half with like a canvas curtain
like a wagon cover so in the back half
of the house they had their living
quarters in the front half of the house
they set up like a little bit of a
general store a little bit of a
restaurant they I think they had a bed
in there like where travelers could stop
and get something to eat and rest before
heading out on the trail or whatever
they either called it the bender in or
the wayward in or the bender tavern or
whatever it's I've seen it called
different things but it kind of got
around that that was there cuz this was
kind of one of the main you know there
wasn't much right on this trail and
there were tons of people like going out
west so that's kind of how that took
place there
so what you describe is kind of like a
pretty much makeshift little Lodge /and
yeah it was really just a house yeah it
was essentially like a rest stop right
there are photographs of the house that
were taken at the time it's not tiny but
it's not real big either
what kind of you're not talking about a
log cabin this is a real no it's a wood
frame cabin pretty much it's just like
made of wood it's just like a
rectangular house and it's just they
have one room yeah that was divided in
half for a piece of canvas right so that
was dividing the front from the back you
know also on this land the mother and
daughter had also planted at
Aker vegetable garden it was an orchard
they had a bar in there they had a
Corral so like when people stopped they
could you know put their animals up and
things like that
now everything no one kind of suspected
anything about them
at first the the elder Bender's monpa
they were kind of crabby and they kind
of kept to themselves
evidently but the the Son and the
daughter would often go to Sunday school
and apparently they were pretty social
and stuff like that now there were
rumors in the community that these two
were not brother and sister but were
husband and wife okay no one is quite
sure how true that is but they said you
know contemporary reports of the time so
well they acted more like husband and
wife there's no records of their
marriage but it could have been
common-law yeah it was back then yes so
you know so who knows but they're saying
they act they didn't really actually
brother and sister okay
now why would a couple have adopted
another couple well they both were they
both brother and sister and man and wife
that could be two but I don't think
that's the case because okay here's word
it like I said no one knows for sure
they suspect that the only ones that
were actually related were ma bender and
Kate the daughter they said that
actually was her daughter okay okay now
they don't know if Mon paw bender were
actually married or even if bender was
their real name okay no why is why are
they not knowing I know there isn't any
records but why are they suspecting that
they weren't married okay something's
going on here in this case well it okay
after the crimes and [ __ ] occurred like
I was gonna get to this later but after
the crimes and stuff occurred it came to
light that they found like a Bible in
the cabin in the house and you know
people used to keep their family records
like in the Bible and stuff like that
okay now there was no genealogy and in
Tibet right right yeah now they had
written in the Bible the birth of the
daughter okay although she had kind of a
different name but they're kind of
thinking it was maybe the same chick
okay the Sun quote-unquote was actually
listed as John Gebhardt and it said came
to America July 18
something so I so I don't think that he
was actually their son IV son-in-law
yeah that's what I mean it might have
been son-in-law and like I said I don't
know if mom pot bender were actually
married now the rumors at the time were
that ma bender hmm
had actually that was not really her
name she was actually Al Meera Hill was
she was born and she was born in the
u.s. she wasn't born in Germany they
think John bender might have been born
in Germany right but but the woman
wasn't so she was kind of going under a
different name now they think they've
looked through like marriage records and
stuff like that evidently she was
married a bunch of other times yes and
her husband's died mysteriously bender
was was a suspected poisoner serial
poison well not poisoner they died of
head wounds Oh head once oh all right
that's the story that's just straight-up
serial killer me yeah so that's the
story black widow she mom okay okay so
the trouble starts to arise in about the
late spring of 1871 and there's a body
found the man was just named mr. Jones I
don't know his first name is none of the
sources say so he was found in drum
creek which was rather near the farm and
his skull was crushed and his throat was
cut now initially no one suspected the
Bender's they actually suspected the guy
who had made the claim on the land that
was right by drum Creek but it was never
nothing was really done about it and a
few months later in like winter of 1872
they found two more bodies these two men
were not identified they just kind of
found a bland blur you know buried in
the Prairie and they had the same
injuries head bashed in throats cut so
like I said these two men were not
identified now you might think oh it's
murders and stuff like that and they
didn't really pursue it though because
you have to think this is the western
expansion there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of people
traveling on this trail going out you
know to set up their homestead out west
on all their new land claims so these
are families they have all of their
money all of their worldly possessions
on them so you've got high
robbing these people you have the people
getting lost in the mountains and
starving to death you have Indian
attacks things like that so it wasn't
that weird for people to turn up dead or
to go missing or anything like that so
it's like they didn't make a huge deal
about it right in some ways that's kind
of why the Bender's got away with what
they did for so long because a lot of
the people nobody missed them or like no
one reported them missing yeah if you're
not an American you got imagine this the
whole Wild West and western expansion
period of the United States is like an
apocalyptic Mad Max type situation oh
yeah there is no law and order there was
nothing there aren't even really States
they're just territories there's no
there were no yeah these the you know
when they sent them out like I said when
they sent the Indians to the new Indian
torrid territory which is now Oklahoma
wasn't even Oklahoma yet yeah you know
and there was no state line there yeah
and contrary to what you see in the in
the Wild West movies the towns were a
lot safer than portrayed in those movies
yes it was just out on the trail yeah
you didn't know it because like I said
and particularly during the westward
expansion I mean obviously criminals are
gonna take advantage of the fact that
there's tons of people going out west
with all their [ __ ] all their horses all
their money all their stuff it's like of
course people are gonna attack them and
take all their stuff but usually when
they got into a town it was pretty safe
yeah there they had sheriffs and yeah
you had to check your pistols right and
things like that but like I said it's
not like you see in the movies where
they actually had hookers in the saloon
and fights in the saloon actually the
saloons were men only the hookers were
in the brothels yeah and you weren't
allowed to take guns into a bar that was
you know that was just well that's just
from people in guns too and most of the
gunfights had done do with gun fighters
he is drunk us and it would didn't no
not no High Noon either it was just
shooting people in the back well yeah
that's the easiest way people in the
back cuz why would you want to like make
this fix all the trouble yeah this
flighted breakout so we get shot in the
back right so like I'm saying it was a
while before anyone really twig to the
fact that anything was going on okay so
one of the first things that kind of led
to the
it was winter of 1872 and there's this
guy named George long core or launcher
or lunker it's you know there's
different spellings his wife died and he
took his infant daughter I think I
believe his daughter was 18 months old
and he was going to take her out to Iowa
which is where his parents lived and he
was going to you know start a new life
after the death of his wife so he packs
up the baby and he packs up all the
stuff and heads out to Iowa and he never
returns now it so happened that before
he left he had bought horses and a
carriage and stuff like that from from a
good friend of his who was also his
neighbor and his neighbor's name was dr.
William Henry York hmm now William Henry
York got very upset and wondered what
had happened to this man and his baby so
he said well I'm going to go find him so
he heads out along the trail because you
know it was the Osage trail everybody
went that way so he knew where he was
going okay so dr. York gets to Fort
Scott and he's coming back to
Independence Kansas which is where he
was from he never makes it home so he
went to look for the guy with a baby
he doesn't come home either okay at this
point it transpires that dr. York had
two very powerful brothers one of them
was a colonel in the military and one
was a Kansas state senator so obviously
they're like okay well we have to find
out where this guy went and at this
stage too it should be said this year
and a little bit into the later year
there had been like a lot of rumors as
like man a lot of people are going
missing at this in this one area the
Osage trail and isn't that strange so
there had been rumors circulating that
there were an unusual number of
disappearances yeah so the one brother
Colonel Edie York he says well I'm gonna
go and find my brother
so Colonel York he's got 50 guys and
he's gonna go and go all along the trail
because he knew where his brother was
going and he's like I'm gonna question
all these people and everything like
that so Colonel York in March of 1873 he
arrives at the bed
in yep and he says I'm looking for my
brother dr. Mike dr. York have you seen
him and the Bender's were like oh yeah
he did stay here for a night maybe the
Indians got him ha ha ha you know so
Colonel York's like you know fair enough
that it did happen
so it wasn't crazy or anything like that
so Colonel York is like okay fine and he
stays at the inn for dinner and then
he's kind of still hanging around the
town now a couple of days later he
receives wind that a woman who was
staying at the inn kind of came crying
to like the trustees or whoever they're
like ma bender drew a knife on me hmm
and was acting all crazy and [ __ ] like
that
at which point Colonel York goes huh
maybe these people had something to do
with some of these disappearances right
so they go to question ma Bender about
this situation yeah now John jr. the son
he says oh that woman was here and she
was being an [ __ ] she's a witch and
all this other kind of stuff and my mom
was just trying to get rid of her and at
this stage now like I said everyone
thought that my bender couldn't speak
English right but she got mad and she
said the woman was a witch she cursed my
coffee so I was trying to get rid of her
and all this other stuff they're like oh
she really does speak English sure sure
sure yeah and she understood English
just fine so again these people are not
what they seem
all right so at that stage like I said
York is suspicious and all this other
stuff and then at this point Kate says
hey you know Colonel York why don't you
come back to the house by yourself on
Friday night and I'll use my psychic
abilities to tell you where your brother
is right and I think Colonel York is
kind of like no right you know I mean
because that sounds a little fishy so
the the men cuz you know York had a
bunch of men with him and the men were
like I think these this family's up to
something these people and like some
neighbors that they had to he's like I
think they might be in on it let's Lynch
them who and so York was kind of like no
we can't do that we don't have enough
evidence or
anything like that now because of all
the disappearances and [ __ ] like that in
the area like some of the people around
in the town had started to think that oh
maybe the Indians were killing all these
people off so they got together like a
committee meeting and they were gonna
talk about it now Colonel York was at
this meeting PAH bender was also at this
meeting as was John Jr so they all start
talking about you know the
disappearances and where's everyone
going and stuff like that and the
trustees come over the play like oh well
you know what we're gonna do
we are gonna search every homestead in
this area and see if we can find out
where these people went now as I said
before PHA bender and John Jr were at
this meeting so after the meetings over
everyone kind of lost track of the
Bender's no one was watching them three
days later someone is driving Pye
driving by the house the bender in and
noticed that it is abandoned hmm he's
like the there are still animals that
are starving outside like all their [ __ ]
is gone right so now everybody starts to
get really suspicious right well we're
gonna go search this homestead and now
since it's right at the halfway point
when we get back from the break I'll
tell you what they say
all right so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so now we're back from the break so the
guy drives past and notices the cabin is
abandoned right so he says okay well we
need to search it now it so happened
that a couple days after that like the
weather was really shitty it doesn't
really say what the weather was I don't
know if is a tornado or snow storm or I
don't know what it was but so they
couldn't search the house for a few more
days okay they call for volunteers they
get like a hundred dudes right and they
come out to search the house
now they go in the house all the food
and personal possessions and stuff like
that are gone but it smells really bad
in there all right so as they're
searching they find and it didn't smell
bad before uh not that anyone ever said
or so they find a little trapdoor
underneath the bed in the living
quarters it's nailed shut okay that's
where the smell is coming oh [ __ ] here
we go well they pry open the trapdoor
and there is like a very very small
cellar it's about I think it's six feet
deep seven feet square all right with a
little stone bottom right at the bottom
is covered with clotted blood huh so the
guys are kind of like okay well we got
to figure out so they go down to the
bottom they chip through all this stone
and start digging around down there they
don't find anything the smell is from
the blood that seeped into the dirt
underneath so they go back up now this
little cellar is where the vendors
actually lived behind that curtain yeah
it's in there living well a little it's
a little bit behind like if you look at
there there are actually little sketches
drawn it's like how the layout of the
place was yeah the trapdoor is kind of
like a couple of feet behind where the
curtain was so it was in their living
quarters so you couldn't see it from the
front part but it wasn't that far behind
there it was just little feet behind
there so basically they lived on top of
this trapdoor yes so then the guys are
like okay well there were no bodies down
there so basically all the guys picked
up the cabin
yeah and moved it over okay and then dug
around all in there they didn't find
anybody's in there either but then some
of the neighbors were kind of like you
know the land in the
you know the vegetable garden and the
orchard that land always seemed like it
was freshly plowed maybe we should go
check that out right so some of them had
like metal rods and stuff so they start
poking them into the dirt
yeah almost immediately they find the
body of dr. York Dam he wasn't even
buried that deep like his feet were only
a couple inches under the dirt right
head bashed in yeah throat cut Mans they
found him now all that you know they
they searched all that evening until it
got dark and they found nine more places
that they thought also might be graves
they said okay we got to check these in
the morning the next day when they dig
around they find 8 more dance total of 9
so far yeah so far
they also found one in the well that's
10 well let's see it like I said they
don't know how many people have said
these people get away with it they threw
a body into their own what under their
own drinking water I don't know
obviously they found a body well it was
dry well it might have been you know
throw a body in your own drink the bar
well unless you're stupid yes well yeah
so pretty much all these bodies same
thing head bashed in throats cut they
did find the body of mr. long core and
the baby daughter uh the baby daughter
she her head was it bashed in but they
think they might have just that she was
just suffocated by her dad's body like
they just buried her in a Thea they just
buried her life
they also found another body that they
think was like a little girl
yeah she didn't have any injuries on her
either so they thought maybe she was
buried alive or maybe suffocated
strangled something like that they also
found a shitload of body parts okay
aside from the entire bodies they found
and the body parts which didn't match
any of the bodies that they found
they're thinking 20:21 people at least
like I said and they don't know if my
bender like killed some people before
that also because some of her husbands
were rumored to turn up dead also right
obviously all the people that were
searching this place were super pissed
off and they went over to this other
German
immigrant named Brockman who was
apparently a friend of the Bender's
right and they put a rope around his
neck and hung him from a beam damn and
started like interrogating him like ask
him what he knew and stuff like that
he's I don't know anything I don't know
anything so they let him down and then
they put him up again they did it like
three times they were like trying to
torture a confession right but evidently
they couldn't get anything out of him
don't feel too bad for him though
because he was a piece of [ __ ] as I will
get into later okay but um so while they
were in there like I said they found the
Bible that led them to suspect that
these people were not really related or
were not a family in the strictest a
crime family right so like I said in the
Bible it said things like the girl that
was born who were we're assuming is Kate
bender was actually born Johanna bender
born in 1848 and then John Jr who was
supposedly their son actually there was
a there was a something in there that
said John Gebhardt came to America on
July 1st 18 whatever year now are they
sure that that's their Bible that's not
a but well it was found in their house
it could just got that officer he killed
true is the handler did they do it like
a handwriting comparison well I'm saying
it was a Bible that was found in their
possession um there was also a
transcript in it that said Biggs
slaughtered a January 8th okay and one
that said he'll departed all right which
I don't know what that means right all
right so after that I mean this was like
huge news like people like reporters
came from everywhere and like checking
this place out the cabin and everything
on the land was completely dismantled by
souvenir hunters because that's what
people did back in the day they just
came and took rocks we'll look I got a
rock road well and I got a wood from the
house and also she cousin so nothing
remained right and actually even
nowadays there's nothing there it's just
like a big flat Prairie so this family
quote/unquote are multiple murderers and
we have to find them because they have
no idea where they went to right so they
start following the trail they found
their abandoned wagon about twelve miles
away hmm
and all the horses were starving and
stuff like that oh the horses
with the wagon yeah okay so they had all
got in it now they found it in the town
of fair they think what happened is that
the family went so far as their which is
12 miles they left their wagon and at
that point they think that the family
bought train tickets and headed for a
town called Humboldt now when they got
to a town called chanute I think that's
how you pronounce it the two kids
quote-unquote John jr. and Kate took
another train and they went south to
Texas now it was thinking they were
thinking that those two went to there
was like kind of an outlaw County or
like an outlaw town on the border
between Texas and New Mexico okay and
they think that's where those two went
but no one would follow them because
they said every time like police or
sheriffs or whatever go to follow
somebody to this outlaw territory they
don't come back all right so so they
don't yeah so they don't know if that's
where they went but that's what they
were speculating because they did head
on a train headed south so they didn't
go after them MA and pas they apparently
stayed on the train until they got to
st. Louis and then they were lost track
of now later when all this [ __ ] about
the family came out they you know other
witnesses who had actually survived you
know who had actually stayed in the inn
and had bad things happen to them but
survived kind of came forward and
started talking about the story so this
is what the family would do they would
basically they didn't pick on everybody
because apparently a lot of people
stayed there it was kind of the only
place in this area but when they had the
target individual they would get Kate to
kind of distract them like flirt with
them and breathe their fortunes and all
that kind of stuff and they would make
them dinner they would say you know sit
at the table and sit at the place of
honor is what they called it right and
it was the chair that was directly in
front of the canvas right you know about
thing behind that thing yes so they said
it was so close and if you see the if
you see the diagram it was so close that
your head was kind of touching the
canvas when you sat down at the table
s'okay to be talking to them and stuff
like that and either paw bender or John
Jr would come up behind the canvas and
hit the
person with a sledgehammer yeah in the
side of the skull Dan they would fall
off the chair
one of the women either MA or Kate would
then slash their throats to make sure
they were dead Dan they would drag them
to the cellar mmm they would throw them
down in the trapdoor which was only a
few feet away and then later on they
would kind of clean up they would they
would strip them of whatever they had
and then they would bury them out in the
orchard or in the garden huh the strange
thing though is that even though they
did steal all these people's stuff
they're some of the people that they
robbed from didn't really have anything
I was Thor didn't have much of anything
that's what I was thinking
yeah it didn't seem like they
specifically targeted people like they
took their money they took their stuff
if they had any stuff I must have been
doing this for pennies because look at
them they weren't wealthy no you know so
I think most sources I read speculated
that yeah they were profiting from it a
little bit but they were just doing it
because they liked it yeah it must have
had been because they said they really
didn't get a huge amount of financial
gain and actually if you look and I
think Wikipedia has like a list of all
the of all the victims and how much
money they supposedly had on them like
once like some of them had a significant
amount because they were heading out
west to set up an at home set or
whatever but some of them only had a few
dollars or didn't really have other
signs of cannibalism not that I ever saw
they don't that I ever they weren't
getting a meal out of it no it's a you
know now some of the newspapers that
some of the contemporary newspaper
reports said that the bodies some of the
bodies had been quote-unquote in
decently mutilated so I'm not entirely
sure what the connotation of that is
maybe it just meant cutting to pieces
that's what I mean they might have just
been cut up because they did find body
parts that didn't match any make them
easier to transport yeah so maybe they
were just like cutting them up to do it
cuz I don't think they weren't like
raping them they weren't like they were
just taking their [ __ ] and just burying
them in the garden that's why they kill
some they kill an adult that was
accompanied with a child that's kind of
a wood that's kind of cold but it yeah
and like I said one of the other bodies
was like a young girl - maybe that
particular victim the father or whatever
had money they could really but yeah so
later on it came to light that some
people that had stayed there you know
had some kind of stories about it you
know they thought it was weird at the
time but you know they're not gonna
reside in no they were murderers murder
but then like afterward they came
forward like oh well that explains that
you know I mean what kind of things what
kind it was just kind of like okay so
here's this one guy and his name is
William Pickering and he stopped at the
inn and he was gonna eat and stuff like
that and they told him hey you know sit
at the seat of Honor stuff and he's like
it I don't really want to because it's
like it had kind of stains on it so he
didn't want to sit there and he's like
at which point Kate bender started
threatening him with a knife like she
got really mad yeah you better sit you
better sit over there and like with a
knife so he was like yeah I'm out of
here okay you got the [ __ ] out and there
was also a priest that stayed there yeah
and he said that he had seen the dad and
the son like kind of coming out from
behind the canvas with hammers and he
took off for us so you know he probably
would have got bashed if he'd stayed
there right and the same thing happened
to two guys who stayed there and they
said they didn't want to eat dinner at
the table they wanted to eat at the shop
counter all right at which point the mom
and Kate got really really pissed off at
them and right then the two guys came
out from behind the canvas with a hammer
and stuff and so they took the [ __ ] off
to they saw they saw the trap yeah there
was just like you know and like I said
they probably don't report it at the
time because it's like yeah that was
scary but they didn't really think
anything was gonna happen to them I
guess so but you know after the [ __ ]
about the murders came back to that oh
well okay that'll make a movie about
this and crustle is in it was a whole
lid off this like somehow the hateful
eight that's a it would be weird and
like I said they did make a movie about
it last year I haven't seen it yet but I
did see the trailer now they also said
that the cabin had several bullet holes
in the roof and the walls and stuff so
they don't know if like when some people
got hit like they didn't get knocked out
and they were trying to shoot their way
out like defend themselves you know but
evidently that wasn't the case in most
of the most of the time because most of
them ended up getting killed now the
weird thing about the end of the benders
is that no one is ever really sure what
happened to them afterward they pretty
much just vanished because they were so
famous and be
that was like a huge reward out like for
their capture I think it was $3,000
which in today's money would be like 60
grand so so there were a bunch of people
that came forward and said and you know
this wasn't like a lot of people didn't
know what they looked like right you
know there there were some ten types of
them there were like you know [ __ ] like
that but there wouldn't like a lot of
photographs back in those days it was
easy to vanish right I'll tell you what
they did is that they just sold whatever
they had or divided up anything that
they had the money and everything
possessions and they all split up yeah
well they just for sure that the two
quote unquote kids and the quote unquote
parents that they did split up at some
point okay so I think they all ended up
being individuals eventually yeah I
think just like I said I think they
speculate that the only ones that were
actually related were ma bender and Kate
they said they actually do think they
were mother and daughter for real yeah
but the other ones they're not really
sure so yeah so they were like all these
rumors going around like it was all
assumed names I bet you that those boys
had no names no they don't think that
there's were their names you know there
were all these vigilante groups that
kind of form that we're looking for them
and things like that and a bunch of the
groups kind of came forward and go like
yeah we got those [ __ ] and [ __ ]
like that like you know one group said
that they have lynched them yeah one
group said oh well we shot all of them
except for Kate we burned her alive
you know we threw them in this river
we've killed them all and buried him on
the Prairie and [ __ ] like that
but you know nobody ever had proof
nobody ever you know like I said there
was a big reward no one ever claimed it
so no one had enough proof that they got
away to do yeah so I'm kind of thinking
they got away the thing is that over the
ensuing years because the murders were
so heinous and because you know because
they were so infamous pretty much I mean
people kept looking for them like for
many decades every word and there were a
lot of kind of you know legend and
folklore kind of grew up surrounding
them now there was some speculation that
paw bender that he might have been like
his real identity might have been John
Flickinger or Flickinger no one knows
for sure
but some people think that that's what
his birth name was and that he was
actually born in Germany now a man named
John Flickinger did commit suicide
in Michigan in 1884 but they're not sure
if that's who it was
now that same year though it should be
noted that a man was arrested in Montana
and this man looked a lot like the
description of paw bender this man was
arrested for a murder he had committed
in Idaho in which he had killed a victim
by hitting him in the head with a hammer
so they arrested this guy and they're
thinking okay well maybe this is PI
bender so they sent word back to the
town of cherryvale in Kansas which is
right around where the where the house
was and said can you send someone out
here to identify this guy we think it
might be pop ender so before that could
take place because obviously [ __ ] took a
long time back then this man caught his
own foot off to get out of the leg-irons
dam and bled to death dance so by the
time that a guy got there from
Cherryvale they said the body was so
decomposed that they couldn't tell who
the [ __ ] was so was that pop-under who
knows that does seem weird that he
killed the guy by hitting him in the
head with a hammer cuz that's definitely
the dad's MO but he still had motive to
run because he was probably facing the
gallows
right so actually whether or not that
was John bender no one knows they
actually said that after he died local
saloon stole the skull and displayed it
as poe bender skull for many years until
it disappeared no one knows where it is
now
now as remember what I said before how
they kind of lynched that Brockman guy
that was a neighbor yeah okay well later
on it came to light that the Bender's
probably had help from like neighbors
and other people in the area because I
think it was at least 12 or 13 people
that were around the area that were also
indicted kind of his co-conspirators
how'd that happen
um some of them actually helped the
Bender's get rid of stolen goods why
from the okay from the bodies and things
like that one of these people had
evidently forged a letter from one of
the people they killed like that a
letter back to his wife saying hey I got
here and I'm fine and stuff like that
many accomplices so yeah it's it does
seem to be the case right and this this
Brockman fellow also was kind of in on
it but like helping to dispose of stolen
goods and stuff like that incidentally a
couple of decades later the Brockman guy
you know the guy that was lynched or
whatever he would actually be convicted
for raping and murdering his own
daughter Dan so you know yeah like I
said don't feel too bad friends okay you
know so and a couple of years after that
about five years after that a woman an
older woman and a younger woman were
captured in Michigan for theft larceny
and there was some speculation that this
might be ma bender and Kate bender um
the reason that they thought this was
because the daughter of one of the
victims evidently had had a dream about
her father getting murdered by the
Bender's and stuff like that cuz I mean
her father was one of the bodies that
they found and she had gone looking for
them
and she figured that she had tracked
these people down now these two women
were going by a bunch of different
aliases the older woman was mrs. al Mira
Munro and the younger woman was mrs.
sarah Eliza Davis now it should be noted
that Kate bender they think might have
been born
Sarah Eliza or might have been born
Johanna like I said I'm not super sure
and also they think that ma Bender might
have had 12 children the one of which
was also named Sarah so they could have
been sisters who knows and actually when
these two got captured the younger woman
said oh I'm not Kate bender I am her
sister Sarah but that totally is ma
bender the older woman said I'm not ma
bender but that's totally Kate bender
you know I mean they kind of Newark to
each other now there was kind of a lot
of complication about I mean they were
let go for the larceny charge but then
they got rearranged they thought they
were the Bender's and they did get some
people to go yeah that's them and then
other people were like no that's
not them like they had tintype
photographs of them and some people
thought that that's who it was
but there was really never enough never
enough evidence to really get
inclusively say whether that was them or
not and they ended up having to let them
go so whether that was them I don't know
it might have been probably but like I
say I was like it could have been yeah I
don't know all the details yeah yeah
like I said it's like it's this big huge
like complex sort of [ __ ] about this
case but it's just this [ __ ] is so crazy
and they said the the scary thing too is
that other than a few of the victims
that were identified and you know were
taken back by their families and stuff
like that
most of the victims bodies were not
claimed so actually they were just
buried actually those yeah they well
they knew who they were but no one came
to claim them so there's actually still
a burial ground that as far as I know
it's still there called the benders
mounds where they buried some of these
victims and when they search the cabin
to later on they found the hammers that
they had used and they matched the
indentations on the skull as those
hammers are now in a museum in
cherryvale the bender Museum and they
also found a knife that still had blood
on it which was presumably the one they
used to cut their throats that's also in
the museum collection but you can only
look at it know this reminds me yeah
what's that this reminds me of a Thuggee
cult yeah how that they would kill
travelers yeah is what it looks like to
me is that along this trail they had a
band of criminals form there yeah that
basically vamper eyes the travelers as
they went through their town they tried
to make it like the town industry yeah
because the Bender's were killing them
and then they were using other people in
the town to get rid of all the loot the
stolen loot but it wasn't enough to
really make a lot of profit off of just
like a real you know low-budget
operation kind of speaks to the
desperation of the people of the town
you know they were pretty low you know
I'm gonna say maybe the desperation but
just you know the low quality of the
people in the town you know scumbags
probably yeah which you know thuggy
cultists were scumbags yeah they just
you
religion to justify you know killing
people and stealing what little earnest
thing about this to me it's like well
okay I guess I guess I said before it's
like oh they weren't technically a
family but I guess if the if the
daughter and the and the son were
married or were common-law marriage and
then the mom was actually the mom of
Kate bender then yeah I guess they kind
of were a family of some sort it just
seems weird how I mean whose idea was
this how long have they been doing this
some kind of weird synergy built up
between them that's what I mean that's
what fascinates me but it's like you
know single serial killers are bad
enough yeah and then I'm always kind of
fascinated to by ones that like get a
buddy like to do it with them like you
know we did this show about Leonard Lake
and Jo sang and you know [ __ ] Henry
Lee Lucas and Ottis Toole yeah like
although I'm not sure they were serial
killers those two yeah cuz a lot of
their [ __ ] was lies
well yeah news well I'm just saying that
they killed some people but I don't
think you know even ones where it's like
where it's like couples like Brady and
Hindley yeah that's the one that
disturbs me Fred and rosemary West and
stuff like that man and women couple
eight a male and female couples going
out kill them little girls and weird
[ __ ] like yeah that's totally bizarre to
do but then the fact that you could get
like a family to go along with it cuz
like I said yeah they were doing it for
a profit motive I guess but it doesn't
really seem like the main motive though
well you know it was Victorian era and
that has the profile of the Victorian
era yeah crime families yeah you know
like they have a little mini mafia set
up yeah running through a business with
neighbors helping and sometimes you know
like like the demon who was a the Demon
Barber of Fleet Street in each Street
you know cannibalism was involved too
yeah yeah the good days Dorian arrow was
you know they were nuts yeah I kinda
feel like that could commit a lot of
crimes and get away with it
law enforcement what wasn't any good
yeah and I think maybe like people don't
realize how polluted the environment was
at that time you know there were a lot
of heavy metals and mmm lead and Mercury
and well and people didn't live very
long they were all in very ill health
yet either
water was dirty the air was dirty and I
think it you know mercury mercury and
lead can play hell on the human brain oh
you know and they start getting
aggressive and crazy mad as a hatter you
know can't yet yep that's right and I
think they had a lot to do with it yeah
and I've been the same with the ancient
Rome ancient Rome had real bizarre
behavior and they had a lot of mercury
and lead and yeah letting their diet
I don't think mercury so much but lead
it's funny I was just and I think I
talked about this a little bit when I
was on The Conspirator Mille show
because I was talking about I'm
fascinated by all true crime especially
unsolved ones but I'm especially
fascinated with old crime especially
Victorian era or you know Old West type
stuff you know stuff that's like
pre-1950 just because people tend to
have a misperception of the past right
as they tend to see it in a rosy sort of
way like oh it was so much better back
then they also think it was clean and it
was no way toxic waste you guys I can't
recommend enough this book is it's book
is called the ghost map and it's
basically about how they figured out
that germs in water caused diseases
right it's said in it's in London venue
nothing and it's about a cholera
outbreak in London people don't realize
it the toxic wastes and the filth that
came from leather tanneries and leather
tanneries yeah everywhere it might be
right next door to a butcher shop or
something selling food and they were
using human urine feces and all kinds of
weird blue toxic mixtures that involve
land and and that's maybe there was no
and then it would go right into the
drinking water yeah there was a
regulation there was no conception that
that was bad for you really I don't
think they even really have made that
association it doesn't seem like I mean
I think some people did like I said but
look how long it was like the late 1800s
before they figured out that drinking
[ __ ] in water will give you cholera oh
yeah it took forever for them to figure
that out they thought it was the air
they thought it was like miasma or
something like there are lots and lots
of birth defects and there are lots of
mental problems from coming from damp
toxic waste yeah you know so me
I can remember when I was a little kid
living living in California and New York
even in the Los Angeles basin I can
remember smog oh yeah me and my I
remember saying video cause like coffin
raisin is a little kiss mom was bad in
the 70 again the adults were immune to
it but look Ahead's a gag enough cut you
know make me in my esophagus would be
raw from like you know coughing up smog
yeah and then you know the cars were
burning leaded fuel so there's little
blood particles everywhere who knows how
many IQ points I lost
oh I'm sure it wasn't that many let it
fuel had a lot to do with it especially
if you're in a dense area I think that I
think that had a lot to do with the
weird crimes that you saw in the 60s and
the 70s because I cars were just LED
machines yeah they were just pumping oh
it's fine yeah no catalytic converters
yeah yeah now so there's a similar kind
of thing there's maybe that might have
partially explained I like all the weird
[ __ ] that went on in the Victorian era
and all that stuff cuz I mean yeah you
see [ __ ] up [ __ ] nowadays but I don't
know I just I feel like it was more
[ __ ] up back then I just I don't know
that's incorrect this was happening
along a trail you know yeah but those
people probably came from highly
populated areas yeah a lot of brain
damage and then you know they were just
dumb to they were not educated well
there's there was you know inbreeding
going on in certain areas yeah I saw the
thing about locally in breeding in the
modern era there was some like a group
of trailers three or four trailers at
middle of nowhere and they were just
dilapidated there was they were off the
grid no power and like there were little
kids running around and the the adults
were having sex with the kids and that
the adults were all brother and sister
and their parents were brothers and
sisters and all the you know you told my
family trees that didn't have any
branches on it yeah they had to go in
there and do you know to condemn the
whole place and institutionalize all it
you know all the adults and all the
children to stop it had been going on
for like four or five generations yeah
now I kind of wonder in the bender
family if those two actually we're
brother and sister
and also husband away yeah maybe not
though but like I said they don't really
the only record they have of that guy
was that that his name was John Gebhardt
and then he came to America what in July
of whatever year so they assumed that he
wasn't related but you know he might
have been who knows all right who knows
if any of them related but yeah this is
like a [ __ ] up story and I'm like
really surprised that it's not better
known and I mean it's not it's not just
me like like I said I'd heard of it I
just didn't really know the details but
I've seen people like could comments on
various you know shows about them and
stuff like that it's like man I'm super
into true crime and I had never heard of
this ever yeah and yeah and it's just it
kills me that it's not better known
especially since later on you know they
may be Texas Chainsaw Massacre which is
kind of similar and I feel like it's
sort of based on this and that kind of
stuff about a whole murderous family so
I'm just surprised that it's not better
known and then it took this long for
them to make a movie about and that
there's that was probably kind of common
there's probably lots of that going on
you just they just know that's what I
mean that's what kind of bothers me is
that you know they were at it for so
long yeah and it took so long for them
to get caught it's like how many more
people were like do you remember it's
it's kind of like we did that show about
the Villisca ax murders and I said you
know right around that time there was a
[ __ ] ton of different like just whole
families being slaughtered with an axe
by some random [ __ ] and they
never caught the person or people it's
like who knows how many of those people
were running around doing that it was
something I read I don't even remember
when I read it but they torn down they
tore down a house from the Victorian
period I don't remember where it was
they're just kind of in the middle of
nowhere here in the United States and
they found underneath that house you
know close to a hundred bodies and they
were from a long time ago yeah they were
from the 1800s and there are no records
existed no records really exist of you
know who it was who owned the house and
no no surviving newspapers from the area
you know reported people missing they
don't know what it was yeah that's what
I mean and like I said when the whole
[ __ ] with the bender family is that you
know people went missing off that trail
all the time you know they got lost they
got attacked by Indians they got
attacked by women
whatever it was almost like an
expectation that like well there's
probably a 75% chance you're not coming
back you know and I mean this Dan's back
then yeah that's what I mean it was a
lot more dangerous so and it was a lot
more easier to be a lot easier to get
away with [ __ ] also oh yeah they just
got away with [ __ ] automatically well
yeah you were like no profession and I
think we said this on the hh-hold show
too you could just pretty much move to
another state and change your name but
everybody like Oh fair enough
yeah yeah you really don't want to start
over just move yeah that's all you had
to do yep
all right so that'll do it for this
episode episode 66 about the bloody
benders as always if you're interested
in true crime in general please pick up
my latest book the faceless villain
which is available on Amazon the
audiobook will be available in a few
weeks I promise ya also check out our
page on patreon patreon comm slash 13
o'clock podcast and if you would like to
give a monthly donation if you would
rather just give a one-time donation
donation through PayPal then go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress comm and there is a link in
the sidebar
also check out our latest movie review
slash TV review which was the Logan's
Run TV series from 1977 if you haven't
checked it out already
and that'll do it for the show and we
will see you next Tuesday bye
[Music]
rally
seventy
[Music]
you
[Music]
you